lindsay lohan is engaged i'm like
pushing right now
she and boyfriend bader shamas are all
set to say i do the actress shared the
big news to instagram early sunday
morning posting a carousel of photos of
her alongside her now fiance plus some
peaks at the eye-catching engagement
ring
and we already know how mama lohan feels
lindsay's mother dina tells e.t in a
statement my heart is whole for a mother
there is nothing more important than to
see your children happy and loved her
beautiful new journey begins love and
light so what's there to know about
vader well not much at the moment the
couple first sparked romance rumors in
early 2020 when lindsay posted this pic
to instagram but if you're looking for a
partner what do you look what are you
looking for in a partner
someone who's
hates the spotlight
no seriously someone who doesn't have
instagram like a smart
businessman well lilo you might have
spoken your dream guy into existence
vader is a financier for a
switzerland-based banking firm according
to his linkedin profile and while he
does have instagram his account is
private and features less than 50 posts
so not a bad compromise and thank god
they came through lindsay's love life
update comes just weeks after a big
career one the actress is starring in an
upcoming and yet to be titled holiday
rom-com it's a holiday season
you know i like the crisp cold weather
well she certainly does look gleeful in
this winter setting netflix released the
first look of lindsey and love interest
cord overstreet the film is slated to
debut on netflix next year do you want
to settle down have a family one yeah of
course yeah of course i want to have a
family and kids back in 2019 lindsay
opened up to e.t about what she wants
for her career and love life would you
ever date a celebrity again
i don't know let's see you're dating
right now i haven't met anyone
that's like i haven't met anyone that's
hit those like
i don't know that mark but if you're
looking for a partner what are you look
what are you looking for in a partner
someone who's
hates the spotlight
no seriously someone who doesn't have
instagram like a smart
businessman you're not really gone from
hollywood life you're still in the thick
of it you still want to act
you know would you consider moving back
to hollywood
no
not not move my life no i wouldn't do it
you don't think you have i like having
my private life private um that's
important to me
um which is why i love living in dubai
but
no one thing at a time is how i think of
things for this right now so it's not
like i've stopped um
just doing things differently it's just
because it's not to everyone else's
agenda i love acting that's never gonna
stop i'm always gonna act